hello everyone my name is Trevor Jones
and this is Android developer office
hours for the week of august first 2012
this week's topic is smooth anger
performance imported you is with our
special guest for money also with us
today is alex lucas and Roman Nurik via
video from New York so for those of you
who are doing this with the first time
we will just show every wednesday at two
p.m. pacific and our goal is to answer
your questions about android app
development if you're watching live feel
free to hop on to our google+ hangout
where you can ask us questions either
via video or if you don't have a webcam
audio and text questions are perfectly
acceptable to we also have a moderator
page to least a vote on questions
beforehand so we're going to go ahead
and start by reading off the top of that
list and as we go along live you guys
are certainly welcome to vote on the
question if you think we should answer
next so let's go ahead and get started
first question from the moderator queue
this is from through age in wheaton
illinois and he asks on app is having
issues with hebrew text and val points
rendering to the left of the center
rather than directly below is this a bug
with skia and is there something we can
do our at in our apt to fix this so i
have an answer for that it is kind of a
bug and skia kind of a burden the OpenGL
OpenGL pipeline and kind of bugging the
fam work the issue if that's interesting
to use that we don't have any support as
of jelly bean vertical positioning of
glyphs with the complex complex
character sets this is something we've
been working on and we already have
fixed this issue internally so a future
version of android will have a much
better support for latin it should
actually work in the next release of
android okay excellent
okay so let's go ahead and move on to
the next question then so this one comes
from a kill from ashburn virginia and he
asks why are objects and auto and boxing
not recommended that's two questions not
to say why are objects are committed
why's auto unboxing not recommended and
I'm not sure that's entirely accurate so
how it's a new version and I put this
beforehand joining him or feedback on or
trim it Morgan answer on this okay so to
address them both individually white
objects are not recommended it's not so
much that we're saying don't use objects
it's the java program it's an
object-oriented programming I mean the
android framework itself is full of lots
of objects objects about in themselves
the bad thing right what we're really
going for is don't use objects
gratuitously where you could where you
can do just as well with a primitive
type for instance so you can you can
pretty easily replace emails with with
simple integers that's just you know a
static constant integer right Sammy
different for those of you don't know if
you use an e Newman object or in Java
that does get translated into a
full-fledged Java object which is a lot
of overhead for if all you want is
something you can interview right and
then if you have a a large collection of
objects that have the each allocating
and properly attached to or something
that is another large collection of
object if using enums instead of just
normal integers so we're really the same
don't use them if don't use them
gratuitously or excessively i4 auto
boxing it's more or less the same thing
because it look if you have like a large
collection of your iterating over and
autoboxing is going to create integer
objects like very good so we're just a
normal integer would work fine you're
going to be creating objects on the fly
in a loop and it's going to be pretty
wasteful like slow things down a little
bit and use it way more memory sorry so
one one or two auto and boxing's here
and they're probably fine right but you
probably don't want to do it inside of a
loop every time that goes through
generation yeah
another object created yeah and oh yeah
the important thing to remember is that
you should only avoid using objects into
boxing in performance critical cut paths
so in out draw a measure if you have
your own customer algorithm that needs
to move you know fast you know better
listener when you click on the button
it's okay to create an object because
that's not going to happen very often so
it's up to you like you understand your
application and you know like what
pieces of code are called very often and
this is where you have to be careful and
also we offer you many api's to avoid
creating objects or to help you reuse
objects of wantin two are talking about
auto boxing very often comes from using
integers inside the hashmap well instead
you can use the sparser ray classes we
have that lets you avoid the 02 boxing
and gives you the same features and
benefits of the hashmap alright so I
think that's pretty well covered so
let's go ahead and move on to the next
question this one's coming from Martin s
in Northwest UK he asks what are the
best tools for tracing performance
issues I have a slight pause and
starring activity and I can't seem to
track down the issue Ramon you want to
yeah so we have two tools that work to
three tools you can use in the SDK that
you can use to to track performance
issues the first one is called traceview
Tracy Letts to profile the the Jedi Code
inside your application and you can see
how much time you spend in every method
in your application you can also use
this trace that was introduced into
jelly bean the best i can recommend if
you want to know more about this race
you should look at the google i/o video
that we posted a couple weeks ago where
we present the tool a little bit and you
can also use the DDMS allocation tracker
if the performance issues comes from the
garbage collector then the DMS will help
you figure out where your educating
objects and why then you can fix that in
your particular case because it happens
when you start the activity there are
two things you can do you can either go
in the developer settings and set your
application as the google the debuggable
application and then there's a checkbox
you can turn on that tells the system to
wait for debugger before attaching so
you can basically let your application
wait until you're ready to start
debugging and as soon as you're ready to
start debugging you can start tracing
you so you can
capture the startup of your application
you can also use trays you from code in
android OS the debug we have two methods
start method tracing and start method
tracing so you can programmatically
capture a trace that then you can open
in traceview so if you just type in the
from the shell traceview and then the
path to the trace file you can open it
and this is a really good way to capture
only your very specific part of the life
cycle of your application and this is
actually something we do a lot
internally we use these methods to
capture the startup of our apps and see
where we're spending time okay thank you
so unless you have anything else to add
on that Alex I think we can move on to
the next question then so this question
is from VT and it I believe this was
actually just voted up so what parts of
an application does the jelly bean
application encryption protect the
developer changelog mentions application
assets and this is a bit unclear is it
possible to disable this encryption for
an application so I don't think we
actually have any experts on the
encryption process here so I'm not sure
we can go into details to what's
protected precisely if somebody does
know feel free to jump in but I mean the
overall goal is to make it so that once
an apk has been sent to a device it's
not possible for you to just go and
casually copy that off of a device the
idea being if you get an apk from
Android for tuning Google Play you know
we don't want you to go and copy that
onto some site where it doesn't belong
so exactly what is encrypted is less
important in the fact that the APK can't
be removed from the device if you're
getting it through google play now I'm
actually not sure but rado do Mike know
this one do we use it we use encryption
even for free apps correct yeah yeah
that's why I thought so for anything
you're getting through google play it is
going to be encrypted that said if you
really do want to go and distribute your
app in a way that is unencrypted you're
always welcome is the application
developer to go ahead and publish the
APK to a website apks that are produced
through the
during development tools are not
encrypted the encryption is a side
effect of loading them on through an
application store such as Google Play so
users will still be able to sideload
your application if you choose to
publish it and then encryption isn't an
issue all right so I think that covers
that one so let's move on to the next
question so I tap it locked right there
alright so this one's coming from
Michael what's the best way to duvall
large images I receive an 800 x 600 jpg
with 8 15 frames per second currently I
create a bitmap with bitmap factory and
draw on the Envoy invested Rob bitmap i
added dooming and panning but it doesn't
feel smooth is there a better way to go
about doing this Saudi there's no simple
answer to this question and as often
with performance questions the the real
answer is it depends so the question is
a little too vague together to give you
a real answer so for instance are you
applying color filters to that bitmap by
using alpha are you scaling the bitmap
are you decoding the bitmap in the
ondraw method in which case that there
will be a big no-no on what kind of
device are you running are you using a
hardware acceleration so without having
you know and answer to all those
questions I can actually help you the
best i can tell you is to use trades
user profile your application you stress
me to see where you're spending your
time because maybe you're not spending
your time in drop it man maybe it's
somewhere else and and yeah without
knowing more about the app it's really
difficult but you should be able to draw
such a such a bitmap like this is not a
big bitmap and actually the size of the
bitmap doesn't really matter as long as
you're not scaling down to a very tiny
size so there must be something else
going on in your application all right
so our next question comes from a
mysterious unnamed person named X I've
actually got a live question from the
Hangout Oh put them on here excellent
yes let's go ahead and we'll get to XS
question in just a moment so oh hey
Roman yes another question on question
trying to stay up to date on the adk
tools there
k tools when the new versions come out
for example I saw last week there was a
20-point 00 point one released and is
not listed in the news of the tool sai
developer site what's the best way to
give up to date with what's with what
has been released okay so as far as the
major releases we definitely in apps
those both on the android developer site
developer android com as well as the
android developer blog now it's always
possible to go overly say a minor
release so for example you know 21 or 20
dot one dot ones yeah depending on the
extent of the release and we usually
don't denounce those because there's
really nothing really noteworthy about
them it's probably some minor bug that
was found that for whatever reason was
considered important enough to merit a
fix so usually the best way is just to
periodically run the SDK manager and
then it will don't flag those updates
automatically of course besides the
stuff that's released as part of Android
Open Source end from google there's a
lot of other companies that can release
add-ons as well you know there's someone
there from Intel from Samsung HTC so
there's a lot of sources to keep track
of definitely you do want to keep track
of the stuff from Android what writing
though there's two key manager but it
wasn't showing up on there and then I
finally do I turned off I like closed it
out rebooted turn back on it found it
and I've since them disabled caching see
if I hope that's going to do anything
and it not cash was out there but yeah
there is a refresh option in the file
menu it's possible that just to get
there was some cache data locally that
was causing a problem it will eventually
pick up those changes though so okay
yeah if you just launched it
periodically that's probably the best
way to watch out for those released
tomorrow releases both from google and
everyone else doing those stories on the
Twitter account and Google+ accounts
that we have 400 developers not usually
so yeah you know Sarah unless we notice
a really big bug then we might mention
something but if it's just a routine oh
just a routine patch to you know to one
of the existing major releases right so
sometime user 20 were coming out your
the preview run one two and three and
that was nice then 2101 it's like okay
you change the build.xml file yeah
effects are doing so that said you know
I I definitely hear hear what you're
saying there that maybe we should
I realized is a bit more so I'll pass on
one trust the team but maybe we can just
get near post something to Google+
probably doesn't want a full blog post
if it's just a one-run change but yeah
we Google Plus is probably a pretty good
medium for that so uh yeah actually
videos right here he manages our Google+
account so you probably yeah consider
the feature request files alright so
let's go ahead and now go on to excess
question actually both before I'll start
should point out that Michael who's
question Vermont sort of answered
generally if he's listening to hang out
or if he's on Michael feel free to just
like popping a hangout and give us more
specific information and we might be
able to give you a more specific answer
yes and then I post everyone here if
we're answering your question we'd
certainly love to see you online and you
know again even if your questions on the
moderator queue you're certainly welcome
to hop on and ask us a question live
right alright so next question here this
one's targeted directly to Ramon so X
asks with ICS Diane mentioned you did
some selective enabling and disabling of
hardware acceleration for the nexus s
how if at all did the better
optimization story change with nexus s
are there any additional performance
tips for low-end devices running Android
4.1 are about so project butter and
jelly bean didn't change much fun
exercise the main reason why we disable
the harbour acceleration in some not
even some apps it was some parts of the
system for instance I believe that it
was disabled in the status bar and the
keyboard we do that mostly to save ram
the nexus s doesn't have that much RAM
compared to other devices and on that
particular device every time we bring up
the OpenGL driver in an AB it takes
about six to eight megs of ram so when
you multiply that by the number of
processes we have it starts getting very
costly we did a lot of you know changes
in the system or we try to be very
aggressive about releasing the memories
actually the memory used
GPU but you know in places like the
keyboard where we don't need to redraw
at 60fps like with the street all when
you when you when you type a key it
wasn't worth it to enable hardware
acceleration and actually I seen the
keyboard might be using software whether
on even on Nexus 7 or Galaxy Nexus so
yeah that that's pretty much older all
there is to it so performance tip for
lower end devices i would say like watch
memory usage usually the the power of
those devices scales down with the size
of the screen so you don't have to worry
too much about graphics performance
because you're going less so it's really
about how much memory you're using and
again you know without I cannot really
answer that question without more
specific details alright so in then once
again if you are watching live because
we'd hop on and and give us more details
so moving on next question is from
Magdala in Palo Alto and the question is
what's the best way to have low lead to
touching games using GL surface view
should i register choreographer that
post frame call back and then consume
all motion events I've received in the
activity thready pepper yeah in the
activity thread at that point I'm
guessing this agreement at a question
for Armand yes so thats actually do
where you should probably do it it's
actually the way the UI itself works we
so we synchronize the drawing on their
own vsync and at the beginning of the
frame we consume we process all the
events that we've accumulated since the
last time we drew so this is very
similar with what we do in the UI what
might happen though in your particular
case is you might get one frame one
extra frame of latin latency because you
will have to to request a render on the
on the joseph is your thread and if you
want that render to be synchronized with
this thing you have to postpone it to
the next frame and this is one of the
reason why for instance we we haven't
tried to do multiple to move the
rendering up to a separate thread in the
UI toolkit is because we can add an
extra frame of latency so you can give
it a try see if it helps and if it's
noticeable then let us know
try to think of other ways of doing it
maybe we can add ap ice to make it
easier for you guys to do that kind of
things and if it's not possible i know
then you know by all means like do that
and that's what choreographer is for ok
excellent HR I'll get a question from
the Hangout sure so when we left but I'm
gonna ask it for you guys anyways sure
go ahead a question is I've seen some
apps use a sideways action bar is this
recommended it feels like it might offer
some extra or better functionality ok so
a sideways action by imagine is
literally in action bar this oriented
vertically along the sides of the screen
I think it's worth we see never moved
right that's that's what I was thinking
as well too so I think the answer there
is it's not a recommended pattern at
this time we do go in periodically
revise our UI guidelines so at some
point in the future we may or may not
decide that that's a good idea but right
now the official recommendation for
action bars is either one action but the
top or the split action bar we have an
action bar on the top and the bottom so
and then of course you can do things
like throw tabs and everything else in
there too this is very similar to a
question they've got in past weeks to
about some apps like Google Play I
believe does this YouTube does this
google plus where when you tap the UP
button it'll cause a additional fragment
to slide out from the side of the screen
with navigation links and our answer
there was the same that what we're
evaluating it if you are ambitious and
want to go and try a new UI paradigms
it's always something you can consider
placing into your app but right now it's
not an official recommendation and
you're actually going to have to add
quite a bit of code to make that work
too because there's no libraries that go
and render that for you so so not
discouraged but not recommended right I
mean I me with all you I things I'll say
all things involving you I our
guidelines are just that they're they're
intended to help guide you towards what
the correct solution is but by by no
means there are hard rules in the end it
really it's the questions really what
makes your application provide the best
user experience which is something that
you have to look at the big picture
right does it blend in with the system
does it make sense is an intuitive does
look nice you know all of these things
are things that you need to consider as
a UI designer so actually we have Roman
on the other end Rowand you want to go
and provide any more feedback or about
this okay first can you guys hear me yes
okay okay so the person asked this
question is actually back on a queue is
here akio do you wanna um you know kind
of elaborate on your question line um
yeah I just think that I've used the
contextual action bar on top and bottom
click on the bottom but it seems like
that it would get in the way i'm writing
a notes app so it seems like that would
get in the way of the like the actual
writing with the palm rest and stuff
it's gotten the way when I've used it um
so I just figured if I put like a
sideways action bar you might actually
help but yeah so I think in some apps
especially in apps that they require
interesting interactions that aren't
just you know single touches or you know
basic gestures things that are you know
sometimes require the full screen like
drawing it fix something complex like
that then you shouldn't feel limited by
our patterns you know if you want to
have actions along the side you know it
may make sense one of the things to
watch out for though is to is to get a
kind of establish a balance between what
looks like a system stuff and what looks
like custom app stuff if you make and
this is potentially kind of unintuitive
but if you make something that tries to
resemble the system graphics too much it
maybe it makes you a little out of place
where as you know if you have something
that's kind of essentially styled in
your own way and it's a sideways action
bar it may make more sense so I think
that it can work and in a lot of cases
the interaction is correct there it's
it's probably better than having things
along the top and bottom but it's
definitely something that requires some
some special thought just to figure out
you know what what's the right balance
between you know establishing pattern or
established patterns and what's really
intuitive and useful for the user yeah
I'll probably keep it down with
assistant normal system UI if I end up
doing it just to avoid like confusion
for the user
sure another thing to think about is you
know you can always show and hide things
so one of the things that happens in
video playback for example is that all
the controls the the system bar the
action bar the status bar all that stuff
can go away with a single tap and
actually there was some new API is in
jelly bean which made this very easy and
made it made the way out very consistent
and stable actually I think it's the
name of the API staple across changes to
visibility of things like that so you
may want to consider doing that as well
so lights-out mode like I think that's
what it's called like that's only
available in jelly bean or no so
lights-out mode is actually available
with honeycomb and later or later but
jelly bean introduced some new things
for devices like the Galaxy Nexus and
the next seven that have navigation bar
a navigation about the bottom and top
they introduced some new API is to make
your way out work even better with that
so it's also the set system you lied
visibility if you I but there's some new
flags in there that make it even better
so I look into that ok thanks ah one
thing I would also note is like as a
firm on mentioned if you have a vertical
action bar it's going to be in it
handedness might become an issue because
if you're left-handed and it's along the
left-hand side of the screen like you're
Paul wasn't actually going to fall on it
a lot so I would say like if it's going
to actually handedness in general
becomes an issue with vertical action
bars in touch screen interfaces so i
would say at least have the option of
moving it to the other side of the
screen or to eat the goods you can put
your hand there nordea or stick with the
top because your hand won't like you
don't rest your hand on the top of the
screen and you also have to keep in mind
to you do have the the system bar at the
bottom which has the home button and so
if your UI is likely to touch an action
bach the bottom of the screen it's just
as likely to touch that system bar as
well too so and unfortunately you don't
really have the option of moving that so
that's something you have to be aware of
as well all right so do you have any
other live questions or should we go
back to the moderator alright so back to
the moderator this so the next question
comes from
so actually the next question is I
battery's dead so yeah so I mean I I
have the next question so the question
is they were the person was looking at
intent service and noticed that the
intense service code was creating a
handler and setting the priority for the
thread to normal instead of background
priority and so the question was what's
the recommended approach for background
services and I think as a side question
is that a bug so at least on my end I
was taking a look through the source
code earlier and I didn't actually
notice any calls to go into the priority
within intent service Java so I'm a
little curious we're on our code you saw
that behavior but as far as what the
recommended practices i remind you do
you want to go and provide tell their I
think the recommend value you know by
default using the default value is
exactly what you want and we give higher
priority to two functions of this review
I in the foreground that the user and
just interacting with our scheduler will
be prior to that so you'd only tsarni
the priority background to get a lower
priority than what's happening in the
foreground I don't I'm not very familiar
with intent services so I'm not sure
what their priority should be to be
background or default or anything else
but I would say that you know given that
that Diane wrote that code whatever the
whatever the part the default priority
is partly like what she meant it to be
but of course we couldn't we should that
skirt of the case and see if there's
maybe a bug there I wouldn't worry about
it too much okay Oh sir so sadly I can't
find a charger anyone over here so yeah
let's do this let me read off your
laptop so yeah so yeah so the next
question is with the voice search app on
the Nexus S it seems like the UI
animation interface can't keep up with
the audio input and response so jank do
you have any insight is to the most
likely cause or tips on how we can avoid
the same pitfalls and this is from an
anonymous user uh okay so i will be
annoying with my answer again so once
again without doing more but exactly
what's going on inside the app it's very
hard to you know to give tips
and I don't quite understand when this
jank is happening but I guess is that it
is something like if your do we have
real time in church research as you
speak do we give you a real time yes yes
under aversions if you're running
android for doc I want to see the
product 0 for that one I think was for
that 0 so that thats Ice Cream Sandwich
we added real-time voice transcription
okay well because I mean there can be
several levels of dankness here it could
be the UI because you know the
admissions are too complicated or it's
too it's too much work for the system or
maybe it's just the time it takes for
the audio to be sent to our servers
processed and sent back so I'm not quite
sure what part of the UI is right here
if the person was the question can join
the hangout and give us more more
details about exactly what's going on or
what the experiencing that maybe we can
we can try to answer the question but as
always I would say you know you strays
you you can just raise view on on any
app and you can see what's going on and
not do that in your applications and if
there's a real problem you should talk
to the people working on the horse
certification okay great so I now have
questions again on my phone I met my
husband without power for the last
couple days I managed to blow a fuse and
yeah my tablet has not charged in a
couple days the fact that it's lasted
this long is actually impressive but
anyway moving back to the questions so
this one comes from Vitaly in albany new
york and the question is what's the
benefits of using an intentservice over
a thread pool executor for neck river
after Network requests are there any
downsides using the thread pool executor
we found that the intent service was
taking about 10 milliseconds to start
and handle an intent is that correct I'm
not hear anything from ramon so nice he
has an answer for this one from church
River isn't in service running into a
separate process yes I said yeah so
intent service actually does create a
service which may or may not create a
separate process but it does create a
separate task ok so depending on what
the settings for
I me because if there is actually a 10
millisecond delay it may just be like
the inter process communication but I
believe that the whole point of an
internal service is to get instead the
life cycle is managed by the system so
you it's all right i mean even within
the same process activities and services
normally should use inter-process
communication to communicate anyway
because there's no guarantee that that
service it hasn't been to be configured
to go and start in a different process
so it's still probably going through
through binder and all of that fun stuff
I mean the difference here between using
a thread pool and engine service is
whether or not you want this request to
happen when the app is in the background
because with the service your app might
live longer in the background that get
killed so you can still execute things
on your internet service whereas if you
are using a thread pool executor and
you're not moving that into your own
service then it's more likely to be
killed so if you want to wake up your
app you know every few minutes or every
half an hour to to make a network
request you'd be better off using the
internet service or your own servants
you can write your own service with with
a sweat particular inside it's just the
intern service is a convenient way of
doing it the thread for signature is
just a loaded voy a pi/2 and it's a
great way to do threading there's
nothing wrong with it as long as you
know how to use it and I know basics
from experience that it's alright so the
next question is coming from Jason and
Jason asks will anybody update webview
to support html5 video yes we have in
honeycomb so as of honeycomb if your
application is hardware accelerated you
get full html5 video support so make
sure your app is either using the target
SDK 14 or you're using the user hardware
accelerated equals true attribute in
your manifest and then you will get a
html5 video support ah excellent now see
I thought it actually hadn't even been
implemented yet so that's great news I'm
work came in so fast I'll take a feature
request go back in time and implement
this trip maybe they fix the TARDIS yeah
it's right there behind me for those of
you who can't see our TARDIS is broken
so normally questions like this we
actually can't answer because
we can't talk about the roadmap for
android you know until things get
released at least but when things are
already implemented that's awesome so
glad we can help you with that so let's
move on to the next question here this
is turn it I've actually got a question
from the Hangout ox14 hangout questions
the question is actually regarding
Hebrew it's supposed to have been fixed
as of the current version of Android but
it's going to be a while before OEMs
actually start introducing this latest
version so it could take up to quote
unquote two years before it's out there
in the wild are there any fixes for this
issue that we that developers can
implement right now not easily I mean
you would have to do be difficult you
have you would have to take your library
like Harper's with with what we use to
shape complex scripts and then you would
have to do your own text rendering to be
able to position the glaze properly so
skia on the canvas API we have a method
called drop as text that that helps a
little bit but it's real broken four
languages back here so it would be
actually pretty difficult to do on your
own and I would not recommend doing it
yourself because it's a lot of work and
it's easy to get to get it wrong so I
wish you know I had the banner answer
for you and I wish I could tell you that
it's been supported since 10 but
unfortunately our answer is it's going
to be in the future version of Android
okay great so next question is coming
from Simon em in Simon in MC from France
either that or the city of Nancy France
i'm pretty sure Simon and Nancy so
assignment will suit in France there is
a visit auntie France okay so yeah I did
see is a strange last name all right so
Simon he asks is there a way to attach a
kind of selector like a stateless
trouble to a textview in order to update
the text shadow attributes with touches
clicks focus etc no you cannot you can
only change the text color
and dry balls in the text you if you
have drawables but you cannot change the
shadow so what you can do though is you
can overwrite text you and then there's
a method I believe called drawable state
changed it's a protected method you can
override that will be invoked every time
the state of the view changes and that
state needs to be propagated to the
drywall so for instance the view goes
from Prai stay tuned on prostate or gets
the focus States or things like that and
from there you can go change yourself
the textural attributes I have to mean
that is not something that we thought
could be useful and I'll think about it
see if we should add that to the
framework but you know it seems to be it
will be probably below on our list of
priorities if we if we divide it okay
great so next question here this is from
Harish from book wherever that is and he
asks when I run my app in jellybean
using the eclipse simulator I get a
warning saying choreographer skipped
2001 frames the application may be doing
too much work on its main thread how can
I overcome this how does